european union ministers have agreed on
the need to update rules governing the
return of cultural objects unlawfully
removed from a member state
the proposals aim to ensure that any
national treasures such as art or
archaeological findings are swiftly and
efficiently returned to their country of
origin
the ministers supported the idea of
broadening the definition of national
treasures extending deadlines for
initiating return proceedings and
placing the burden of proof on the
possessor of the works of art when it
comes to compensation
at the meeting in brussels the council
also threw its weight behind efforts to
ensure media freedom and pluralism which
the eu considers to be one of the
pillars of democracy
ministers agreed on the need for new
transparency and media ownership
ensuring that journalists are free from
political influence and that their
sources are protected
and on the independence of audio visual
regulators
the council was also briefed on smart tv
as many europeans start to use on-demand
services linking their televisions
computers smartphones and tablets
this evolution in interactive viewing
poses new challenges to the way that
audio-visual media services are
regulated but also to control over
advertising copyright and the protection
of children the ministers debated what
these new developments might mean in
terms of risks for consumers and whether
special regulation might be needed